who represent expertise from various
points of view on this on this subject
so we're looking forward to a great
discussion so we have uh
um
chen bang from uh umass amherst he um
um
he's he's a he he's he uh
his work is in condensed matter
experiments uh especially in
superconducting
uh quantum circuits so it's um uh chen
um
that is phd from cornell and the postdoc
at yale uh so he's very uh i think
familiar with all this um
shruti puri uh who is uh
uh
you know who is who is on the faculty at
yale she actually also uh also did um
did her work at at here and uh
she works on um
she actually blends uh brings a physics
as well as a computer science ideas into
into this theoretical treatment of
errors in quantum computing uh systems
so
particularly uh
important for what you're going to talk
about uh
jonathan whom uh
you know as as uh
from eth um
uh who does experimental work in quantum
optics and photonics and as michelle
referred to he's been
he's actually worked on these
experiments in iron traps
and daniel gottesburn who um
in addition to being the
you know inventor of the gkrp
codes that michelle spoke about he
actually
also
created the stabilizer framework for
quantum america action and so
well welcome everybody and
perhaps we can have um we can start with
a few minutes uh few minutes by each of
you uh to comment both on you know
anything you want to particularly
comment on in michelle's talk but also
uh anything else you want to say about
uh
you know about prospects and
and challenges ahead in in bosonic air
correction
maybe um
before this begins uh since um i have
mentioned in my talk
the work of
danielle
jonathan and shooty
i would like to say a few words about
the
work of shang because
i mentioned briefly um other codes are
the books and it codes binomial codes
for instance and channels actually
implemented
those
other codes in addition to working with
them on the cad code
great yeah
so um
uh
would you would you like to lead off uh
shruti or
me well maybe daniel should should start
because he's the inventor of gkp
okay i can start um
so yeah so speaking as as the key in qkp
we couldn't forget the k and the p um
because i have impressive of course but
um i uh you know it's of course very
exciting to see these codes finally come
to realization over the past few years
um
i mean i remember talking to journalists
at the time
so our our paper came out kind of at the
same time as the klm scheme for linear
optics quantum computing and people of
course were asking us to compare and i
remember saying to journalists at the
time well i think r is a very promising
approach but um the first step is the
hardest one
which is why it's taken you know 20
years to get to this point um but but i
the
the the concomitant of that is that once
we've gotten to this point i think we
can expect progress to be much faster
that we can
put together these gates and and
actually start building quantum
computers this way
um so that's very hopeful
another comment i wanted to make is that
it's it's kind of interesting that
that that these codes are kind of the
last refuge of concatenation so in the
early days of fault tolerance
concatenated codes
were kind of the way you proved the
threshold theorem it showed that there
was a way to do you know error
correction that would that would correct
uh to arbitrarily good logical error
rates
um but the subsequent years of course
they've been mostly overtaken by by
surface codes
um and other other error correction
schemes um but but you know we have this
kind of separation now between the pkp
code which is
great i think but not good enough by
itself to take you all the way to a big
fall tolerant computer and so we're
imagining you know concatenating with
another code
um so so concatenation still has a has a
role here even though in other schemes
it seems inefficient um but that also
suggests that maybe it shouldn't have a
role here maybe there's some other more
complicated many mode codes or something
that we can we can get that will kind of
circumvent the the concatenation but
and get us even better performance
so so sorry just just to come back to
what you what you said very quickly you
know so if you if you were to look at
uh classical fault tolerance
you know once upon a time uh
for neumann really thought about
classical fault tolerance and eventually
of course the repetition code was good
enough uh just in hardware
so so could you think of
you know this particular these presonic
codes as as the
morally the the quantum analog of them
and to what extent do they do they go
get there and to what extent do they
fall short of that
um
so i don't i don't know i don't think of
these well there's some
analogies normally actually people think
of the torque code as uh
and and uh an anionic uh encoding
as the air the quantum version of the
repetition code something that's kind of
physically built into your system you
have a hamiltonian
that that whose whose
low energy states kind of naturally have
this this fault tolerance property built
in
um i think of i think of the qkp codes
more
as um
a
quantum version of
digitization of information so you have
which was classically uh and confusingly
is called quantization um but where
where
you know you have a continuous degree of
freedom
and
you just want to encode a qubit or a bit
classically
and so you kind of say well if it's less
than this we'll call it a zero and if
it's more than this we'll call it a one
um but but actually that does have a
certain amount of fault tolerance built
into it right because
you know
if you do that then
um you're kind of
if you have something that's in between
it gets pushed to one side or the other
and so if it's close to kind of your
ideal zero or your ideal one then it'll
get pushed back to that and it'll be
corrected
um and that actually does have a big uh
factor of why why classical machines are
kind of inherently fairly robust because
they do this kind of rectific
rectification
of the the currents or whatever their
their big carrying information is in
order to
to get back to standard states and so
that's that that's that's the thing
that's really hard
yeah i think that that's what uh that's
what i was referring to so
maybe maybe i should have said more that
um the repetition code classically plays
nice with uh with operations one wants
to do
on the data and yeah what extent does
this discord play nice but
i mean i mean classically you also have
the repetition code right because each
bit is encoded in many
electrons or whatever um and and if some
of them go off and do their own thing
that's not a big deal they kind of get
pushed back uh so it's it's kind of a
little bit of both that's going on
classically
um and
um
the the so the the kkp encoding plays
very nicely with the clifford group
gates
um
and so that's why clifford group gates
are relatively straightforward but not
so nice with the non-clever group gates
and that's
so that makes that a bit more of a
challenge
thank you that's that's really helpful
shruti would you
yeah thank you um
so i'm you know i i think that
the reason i joined
this field is because i was really
fascinated by
all these non-classical states that were
being produced in circuit duty it was
just amazing uh to see that you can
actually measure these beginner
functions and now you're making these
super exotic states but then
you know as as i was reading more i
realized that there's you know
more power in these um
in these non-classical states in terms
of rare corrections so this this has
always been very fascinating to me
the thing that keeps me up at night is
um how do you actually control them
because for them to be really good you
want it to be in a nice clean oscillator
with long lifetimes and you know that
you want just them to be sitting idle
but at the same time you want to control
them if there are some errors you want
to control them and the only way to do
it is have some non-linearity somewhere
you then need photo detectors you need
um
uh you know your
um a regular qubit or something like
that and then
um
the fact that
you inherent the the bad properties of
your non-linearity
um and limit the lifetime of of these uh
nice bosonic goods is what really
bothers me and like i i
i'm really trying
to work very hard to to see what's the
simplest way to get rid of this this
problem like how how do we how can we
keep the pristine nature of of the these
was on a qubits without
while still be
being able to manipulate them while not
being able to while not corrupting them
from our you know non-linear controls
um
so i think that's a super interesting
area and i i would really like to find
an answer
oh and maybe i should um mention also
michel michelle uh mentioned these magic
states in the beginning and that's
so in principle you can you can prepare
whatever state you want you know if you
have a if you have a qubit interacting
with your cavity and you have these
control displacement gates you can use
them to make
different states eventually
the quality of the states is going to be
limited by
you know the the state of the cubit and
that's the same problem that i'm talking
about is like how do you
um
how do you prevent this back propagation
of errors from the cubit to the to the
cavity mode
[Music]
but what worries me the most is the
implementation of the toefl gate of all
the non
non-clifford gates
in inner corrective or manner so this is
really the
the big challenge which i think and
maybe the exposure need codes will
have some property that
will make this easier
[Music]
yeah for sure so you know
there has been work recently that
explores using these
using bozonic properties to make
non-clifford operations better i think
even in uh it's been a long time since
i've read the original gkp paper so i'm
sorry if i say something incorrect but i
think even in the original gkp paper
they had some ideas
i think you guys had some ideas about
um
preparing these these magic states in in
not completely fall tolerant but like
somewhat
robust manner um so i think
there are ways to do it it's a question
of
whether we can reach those limits in in
the experiment
great
so move
thanks thanks for these would you like
to say something
chen maybe or
sure yeah first of all i just uh
listening this to this talk
quite a few times already i still
feel very very um
fascinated and impressed with the um
with the new type of fancy microwave
states we can make i i just want to
comment even
like four or five years ago and in
superconducting circuit qed we already
made
many interesting states those rotational
codes and rotational symmetric codes
with the
schrodinger cap states and it still was
not like imaginable that you would ever
take on something like like the gkp and
i mean the code was there for a long
time and we looked at this and
it really doesn't seem like a possible
you can you can you can do it you can do
anything with that but just a few years
later with this
conditional displacement and the
feedback and
suddenly it has changed and certainly i
feel the gkp has a lot of advantage um
good thing going for it going for it
with
essentially all the single qubit the
single cubic clifford comes for free um
which is uh which is a big deal that's
not true for for some of the the other
bosonic codes
um
one thing uh speaking of the um the
future with uh with uh using these
bosonic qubits and i think a lot of
people talk about uh thought tolerance
for sure and especially on the theory
side um i'm more like an uh um
a very
um experimental
person looking looking at this and
especially when we talk about
concatenation on the next level i i kind
of feel uh we are really just the
building bosonic qubits
whether you call it error correction or
you call it a better physical qubit it's
a it's sort of like a different
different ways of looking looking at
this problem so
at some level
um i think we need to be able to compare
to talk about things on numbers on gate
fidelity level if we're going to
concatenate on the next level then and i
think the key really is to have error
corrected bosonic qubits that are
performing that are outperforming like
the best gate fidelities that are
available with other more simple simpler
physical qubits like like trans mounts
so
uh yeah so we are having uh
a good start and i think right now uh
the bosonic codes either whether the the
gkp right now or the cad codes or other
binomial codes these these things we
work on and fundamentally i think we're
we're doing a first order first order
error correction so i think what what
that means is and you can imagine if
you're
if your cavity
improved by a factor of two and your
ancilla also improved by a factor of two
i i like to think about uh cavity and
and zela act together as your as your
system as components of the building
your fundamental block that goes into
the next level so you expect like an
enhancement of a factor four let's say
um of your of your now
this uh this new
physicological qubits and this is this
actually you run the math and you can
see it is true as long as we're talking
about memory lifetime so right now we
see bosonic qubits that are reaching
breakeven in terms of in terms of
lifetime and it is possible to certainly
further improve that and show a
multiplication effect the reason is that
you can
basically keep your ancestor grounded
and not touch it and when an error
happens then you use your ancilla to try
to do correction and with that your
ancestor is only exposed when you when
you need to use it to to correct your
error then then from that you can
actually get a multiplication effect so
that's really the the first order error
correction on the on the building block
level we're looking for going to the
next level um i'm not quite sure that's
true for doing dates yet so i think
really the next push really for for
everybody yes on the experimental side
is to to actually to be able to do good
gaits 99 99.9 level and improving from
there and uh really the bottleneck right
now is whenever you want to do any
non-trivial gates um on the bazonic
qubit or between two of them you kind of
necessarily have to
have to do non-trivial operations with
your ancilla then essentially the gate
fidelity is limited by like your gate
speed against the quality or the
coherence time of your ancilla so from
that perspective
um
we we
we still have a
good amount of work to do as just as
judy said uh how do we really operate
these these bosonic qubits right there
seems to be some kind of you know
conserve conservation law in terms of
how fast you can do operations on your
bosonic qubit versus like how much
you're willing to bring your non-linear
resource into into into the picture
yeah so um
yeah that's just my
a little bit comment on this and yeah
i'm sure there are critics out there and
asking oh how competitive you are
against the the all the all the dozens
of qubits out out there and yeah i think
at some level and it will have to become
compared on on the gate fidelity level
with the correction or
not so do you have a do you have a
prediction about um
you know about the future how
what would your what would your
optimistic prediction be about a
timeline for
the sorts of things that you mentioned
[Music]
um i will have to
yeah i i don't i don't know yet and
i think the
i i can only i at least i can see that
bosonic qubits operating as a as a
memory uh we can do first order
correction and there is a pathway we can
show the multiplication effect and
really get a much better
memory than than physically available
and so in terms of doing gates when
we're going to get to four nines i think
that that that that is still that is
still to be seen and i think and
yeah yeah i'm really seeing this this
effort as a building better
building better
building block units and right out there
we have superconducting qubits and
trapped ions generally you're talking
about 99 to 99.9 so 10 to the minus two
to the minus three level of errors and
that's why
um you have about a hundred qubits out
there and if you build a thousand it
doesn't exactly buy you anything until
you can do error correction because you
you just fail faster with with more
qubits right so so the race really is
about
how do you trade some level of hardware
complexity or number of qubits to drive
down your error rate by another
magnitude or two lower and yeah yeah
we're not there to talk about uh 10 to
the minus 20 error rate yet we're just
learning how to trade quantity for for
quality uh little by little at this
point
yeah so bolonic qubits is one way
to do it and uh
yeah we we still have ways to go to to
see how we we actually do this
great thank you thank you jim
yes i'd like to comment on what chen
said so yes i think the notion he
developed of whether you know the the
gates on
on the bozonic cuba it would be that
superior to
to that let's say between transman cubit
is uh is really a very important idea i
i'd like to
to just um
point out that what i find fascinating
in gkp is that at least
the steel knot
is a simple gaussian operation that
is the kind of operation you do with the
very commonly with amplifiers with a
very little gain actually
this would be a gain of two at most so
so there is a chance at least maybe for
this operation uh that we can do this uh
rather rather precisely
uh it also um i think um
uh involves if i am not mistaken it uh
it is uh it is a gate that fits well
within the with the error correction
but um
so so maybe there are opportunities like
this which we have not seen yet
other opportunities that make the gate
potentially uh more precise
i i'm not too sure as you as you say
about gay times but at least
in some sense that might be of commuting
opportunities with this kind of code to
to make the gate
very precisely because we
we know very well what kind of parasitic
arrows
we
were making with this kind of gate
this kind of gauchon goshan operation
great um
so uh well turning to you jonathan
[Music]
would you like to
sure yeah i can make some comments i
think we're the this controlled
displacement operation for us in trap
diamond so we we work with the internal
states of the irons and we work with the
motion of the ions and this control
displacement is actually something that
dates back years to the sort of days of
day of one and it feels like uh
doing experiments on emotional states in
the ground state in the 1990s
so actually
once we were making squeeze states very
regularly in the lab and we knew how to
apply control displacements it sort of
seemed very natural to start to make the
gkp states in this in the sense in the
way that michel says once you have this
control displacement it's a very natural
tool for gkp states but when we started
to make these states and and do
operations on them you know i looked at
the papers for error correction and
well a lot of these papers told you you
had to do you know phase estimation so
many rounds of sort of extracting
how large the displacement was to sort
of get the precision of the displacement
to many bits of precision
looking at the papers that was very much
the impression you got so one very
beautiful thing about the work that
michelle showed really was that um
this very simple one bit feedback cycle
in a sense can be
actually enough to sharpen these peaks
very high if you have the settings set
right yeah and so this is just a very
nice insight very inspirational in fact
for us it meant suddenly we could go
back and think again about whether we
could do error correction and you see
that we
could in the end but only really because
these guys had simplified so much what
the correction cycle should look like so
uh that was very interesting to me i
think
one of the other things to notice about
thinking about concatenating these codes
uh is well one
we now are doing the correction
autonomously
but if you do your correction
autonomously and aren't able to recover
the syndromes i guess you lose something
when you go to the next level of
encoding
so whether in the end you want to be
doing it autonomously or
plucking out the information i guess
there'll be a trade-off in any sort of
concatenation there yeah
on the other hand there's kind of
interesting aspects i think to these
bosonic codes one is that for instance
you know the surface code really doesn't
like correlated errors but you may well
have correlated errors affecting any
physical system that you have and
there's kind of a nice thing about these
gkp error correction in a sense is that
this correction is going on
locally and providing a local
dissipation channel and i'm no theorist
but i do wonder whether actually that
connects very nicely to decorate the
errors so that by the time you go into
the next level uh you've solved one of
the problems for your next level code
and i think maybe daniel will tell us
that that's total rubbish but
i haven't got the intuition to tell
myself that that's right yeah
so and i think that also to me like is
another hint at what i find attractive
is that some of the
some of the gates and things you know
what you really want to know is whether
the gate errors that you produce are the
ones that are correctable in your code
right that's the end game in a certain
sense and so
finding combinations of systems where
the correction of the errors you're
correcting are the same ones your gate
produces this is kind of like what
you're looking for and
what's nice about the bosonic encoding
in a sense is it's like this
multi-dimensional search in this phase
space that's not so easy to think about
but maybe allows you to find pockets
where
you do find errors that very naturally
fit together with the gates that you're
trying to do
and i mean just to give a sort of notion
of break even from the trapped iron
point of view you never ever will beat a
physical
just for memory you'll never beat a
physical reptile in cubit you know q1
kim has an hour lifetime on his physical
cubit right so what you see immediately
when you're working with those sort of
systems is that
the
you know the game is not to beat the
errors on your qubit there but it's to
beat the areas you introduce when you do
anything to the cubits yes
and somehow this is like uh very sort of
stark in that case and and i think that
propagates also to thinking about these
bosonic systems if you like
so i leave you with that i can say more
of course later and of course daniel now
has a question he has to answer about
correlation
daniel
yeah um i mean
i think it depends a bit uh you have to
go into the details of kind of what the
what the correlated error model is to
say one way or the other
um i mean
obviously if you have a lot of
correlated small errors then
i'm sure they'll be corrected but they
would have been corrected just as well
uh without i mean you know the
correlations don't really uh impact that
at all
if you have correlated big errors then
what that means is that you'll have
different modes that are likely to fail
at the same time and you haven't gotten
rid of that
but an intermediate regime where there's
some where the correlation isn't perfect
and
you know where there's some spread in
the
the size of the error
then you know the odds of having two of
them be on the
the long end where they both fell at the
both both codes fell at the same time
that will be smaller so so you will have
probably some some degree of decoration
but
again it depends on the details of the
model i think
actually just just following up um on
something you had said earlier uh daniel
so you uh yet said that these these
bosonic codes play very nicely with
clifford gates uh did you
you meant not just single qubit clifford
gates but also c naughts and control z's
etc did you yeah that's right and
michelle mentioned that right that uh
that it's just you know very basic
standard elements that that just happen
to preserve the structure of the codes
and and let you do the logical uh
two qubit gates or works for long circle
for days
um
there's a question in the audience by
mohan sarovar maybe i'll uh ask mohan to
unmute and ask it himself
[Music]
sure thanks so much yeah i was wondering
if the panelists could um
comment on the pros and cons of the gkp
encoding versus uh the cat state
encoding
especially with respect to scaling
and building an actual architecture
[Laughter]
at least on the relative merits of um
gkp and cad codes which we we both work
on
in my lab
so so the cad codes um i think um very
interesting and and shruti can uh
comment more on this we we pursue
the catcat um the cat code in particular
and
it's true
that
creates a
fierce cubit a bios logical qubit with
an extremely uh good product protection
of one operator
which
becomes exponential which increases
exponentially with the size of the cab
and then at the expense of a decrease in
the protection of
the other two operators but
the the protection decreases in a linear
manner so this this kind of bias qubit
has also
great advantages
in terms of
constructing
a layer
a layer a code with uh with several
layers
you
if i understand
what shooti is working on correctly
there will be a better threshold
actually for this kind of
architecture so
that that is also
an interesting property there there is
also
a wonderful property uh with the
at least carecats to be able to do a
synod which is topological so now this
is really really interesting because uh
that puts us um in this uh
realm of operations that topological
protection so instead of just uh
doing better memory we could we could do
some
non-trivial gait operation that would be
protected topologically like like for
instance what
you find in the field of majorana from
one so that
that would put these bosonic
cubits
in
in sort of
in the same realm as
as
i as the topological qubit so this is uh
this is very interesting from an
experimental point of view
maybe i can add a small thing that so
they did when you
that they're different so there's we
know the gkb code when you say cad code
they're different varieties of cat code
there's the kerkat which is a stabilized
cat and then there are free cats
um
so dip so what category of cat codes
you're to answer your question i need to
know what category of cat codes you're
mentioning so my favorite of all these
codes is the gkp and the kerkat the
reason being is that
we kind of
know how to do the operations that we
would need to scale up
um
however like by no i mean at least we
have a path forward with the free cat
codes it's very hard to do
the kind of operations that you need for
scaling up uh in any easy manner uh so
we are you know even even over here
theoretically we are trying to find ways
to make these three cat codes you know
on par with
gkps and kirkats
but
yeah the the other nice thing about the
kircat is that you know this problem
that we mentioned earlier about
having to use ancillas to do operations
uh you don't have that problem with
kurcats it's just it's it is a qubit
it's a real qubit you can do all the
operations that you want you don't need
insulars to control it so that's a nice
property and but with gkp is you unlike
the gkp the kerkat is not a fully
logical qubit it's only semi-protected
whereas gkp is in principle you know you
can protect it against all errors
um
so for these various reasons i think for
me gkps and the stabilized cats are kind
of my favorite ones
great um
um
maybe we are getting towards the end of
the timeframe panel but if if if you
have any final closing comments
before we close out
so there was a question uh in the chat
that i could uh could answer
and
it is the um
the the question was
whether the um what causes the overall
shape of the gkp grid
to go down in experiments
uh so
[Music]
so the the question also was uh
about the broader
overall
and uh more pickets in the in the wake
function so i can i can answer this
question so what um
what
causes the the
shape to broaden is uh actually um
photon losses and photon losses but also
um
defects like um one sense um
small small rotations
parasitic rotation
which
may cause because for instance by the
end cellular there is also
the ancillary errors
in our experiment are principally the
cause of
the errors the broadening of the peaks
so that's that's what we were correcting
the the question of whether it is
desirable to have
a broader overall shape
is is linked to the following
optimization so if you have too many big
advances
you you will have you will store a lot
of energy in the code and so you
increase
the rate that which the information is
lost because the um the decay rate is
proportional to the photon number so it
means that you have to correct more
often
and there is a speed limit to the
error correction rate in our experiment
which is fixed by the
without cavity and on or without
and and feedback
so
once uh once you have
by you set a certain error rate uh
error correction rate by your hardware
then there is an optimum shape for the
code you should not really
have too many photons
have too large an envelope because
actually you you that would need you to
correct more often and you can't you are
limited you have the speed limit
so for every speed limit in the
correction rate you there's an optimum
optimum shape for the code
and that's that's what we try to
optimize in the experiment
great
any any further comments by anybody
well um
let me just uh yeah let me
wrap up here by first thanking michelle
for a wonderful talk
this was really enlightening and and
also to all the panelists for a really
great discussion i
really
appreciate it so
thank you all and
thanks to the audience and see you all
next week
okay
thank you
thank you
you